a legacy prequel nobody asked for a
bunch of movies nobody will see and a
Nick Cage vehicle that actually sounds
kind of cool here are the most likely
box office bombs of 2023. in a man
called Auto Tom Hanks portrays Otto
Anderson a widower who has become a
grump after the loss of his wife soon
though he finds a new sense of purpose
when a young Lively family moves into
the home next to him per the movie's
official premise the family's witty
matriarch forms unique friendship with
Otto on the surface this storyline may
sound a little like a live-action
version of up minus the balloons this
movie is also based on an international
bestseller a man called uve was written
by Frederick backman and in fact has
already been made into a movie back in
2015 all of the above might make a man
called Otto sound like a Surefire box
office hit if it were 2003 rather than
2023. Tom Hanks is a great talent but
his long-lived reputation as the nicest
guy in Hollywood makes it hard to see
him as anything but just look at the
critic reception to his turn as Colonel
Tom Parker in Elvis and while that film
earned 282 million dollars worldwide
hanks's box office record has been
spotty lately songs's outings as Woody
in the Toy Story franchise finally a man
called Otto is an adult skewing dramedy
that may be too adult for kiddos but too
sweet for seniors and it's scheduled for
Nationwide release in the box office
winter of January in this current
climate a man called Otto is a movie
made more for streaming than anything
else a theatrical release might just
spell its Doom Spider-Man has one of the
best Rogues galleries in pop culture and
Sony has spent years trying desperately
to mine it for gold the latest victim of
this trend will be Craven the hunter
star of the upcoming movie Craven the
hunter so why will it probably bought
one word morbius the 2022 pseudo
Spider-Man spin-off bombed not once but
twice when Sony Pictures mistook the
phrase It's morbid time trending on
Twitter for actual box office potential
and decided to re-release it for the
sake of a glorified meme yes Venom and
Venom Let There Be Carnage collectively
earned 1.3 billion dollars at the
worldwide box office but that's then
arguably the most popular comic book
super villain whose name doesn't start
with a j Craven is a b-list Villain at
best in the Spider-Man franchise and in
no way does he warrant his own movie and
while you may be thinking that Black
Adam is also a b-list villain one who
recently made a whole bunch of money
you've got to remember that that
character was played by Dwayne Johnson
arguably the most bankable star in
Hollywood and that that movie still had
a tough time breaking even on its
staggering 200 million dollar budget in
marketing costs craving the hunter Stars
Aaron Taylor Johnson best known for
playing Kick-Ass that one guy in
Godzilla and Quicksilver in the MCU you
didn't see that coming
but hey we'll always have the memes
Gerard Butler versus insert disaster
here has been a pretty reliable
sub-genre at the box office whether that
disasters terrorists taking over a
national landmark or simply a load of
out-of-control weather Butler's last
disaster film Greenland found him
battling an apocalyptic asteroid
hurtling toward Earth and to the movie's
producers Gerard Butler vs Armageddon
must have sounded like a license to
print money it wasn't though Greenland
only managed a measly 40 million dollars
at the worldwide box office yes it was
released smack dab in the middle of the
pandemic and wasn't released in North
America at all but 40 million dollars is
still pretty bad for a would-be
mid-level blockbuster and it spells
impending doom for Butler's latest
disaster flick plane in plane Butler
plays Captain Brody Torrance a
commercial pilot who narrowly avoids a
terrible storm only to land on an island
Battleground run by a separatist militia
which according to the trailer is so
dangerous that even the Philippine Army
won't go there anymore okay so plane
obviously sounds delightfully cheesy and
exactly the kind of movie that would
dominate on say Netflix alas the theater
going audience doesn't always go for
concept driven star Vehicles like this
anymore take the recent failure of
moonfall as an example because these
headwinds will be set against it it's
probably fair to assume that plane will
crash and burn at the box office
you're making too many movies Nick
you're working too hard Nick have the
audience miss you more Nick I mean hello
it's my job I pay my bills I feed my
family you're annoying nobody choose
scenery like Nicholas Cage and in 2023's
Renfield he'll finally get to do some
literal chewing as the iconic star will
be taking on the role of Count Dracula
in this horror comedy from Chris McKay
cage plays the count though the focus is
presumably on Dracula's henchmen the
eponymous Renfield who is played by
Nicholas Holt now let's not kid around
here cage playing Dracula in a movie
about his Lackey sounds pretty great but
that doesn't mean it won't bomb for
example everyone thought that Nicholas
Cage playing Nicolas Cage sounded
awesome but the unbearable weight of
massive Talent tanked with only 29
million dollars worldwide on a 30
million dollar budget Nicholas Cage
saving his pet pig also sounded awesome
but Pig bombed with 3.8 million dollars
as did Nicholas Cage going in a Trippy
fever dream Revenge fantasy in Mandy now
cage is arguably in the most creative
parts of his career and many of us would
rather watch these types of films than
endure another Ghost Rider sequel but
there's no denying that moviegoers
aren't buying what he's selling his
movies are there for movie nerds and
cage aficionados to obsess over to their
hearts contents General audiences though
not so much
genres suffer as much as a quality gap
as original sci-fi at one end you have
Avatar Star Wars and the Matrix and on
the other you have movies like Jupiter
Ascending sunshine and we suspect
distant according to the film's official
website distant follows a low-level
mining engineer who crashed lines onto a
dangerous planet and has to beat the
odds to find another Survivor in other
words it's some sort of mix between the
Martian and the gray and while that
might sound cool it's also the exact
kind of movie that needs a bona fide
Hollywood Legend to Anchor It
conceptually distant sounds like the
kind of movie that would benefit
tremendously from proven box office
Heroes like Dwayne Johnson or Will Smith
instead the movie star is an ensemble of
talented yet lesser known names such as
Anthony Ramos Naomi Scott and Zachary
Quinto were still distance constantly
shifting release dates and endless
delays don't Inspire much optimism in
its quality what do you do when there
are no stories left to tell in a
franchise you make a prequel in 2023 we
will finally get an answer to the
question literally nobody was asking
what was Willy Wonka doing before the
events of Charlie and the Chocolate
Factory yes if you've ever laid awake at
night wondering how a young Willy Wonka
met the Oompa Loompas that Wonka is the
movie for you whoever you are you lose
good day sir
back in 2005 Charlie and the Chocolate
Factory earned 475 million dollars
worldwide but that was the same story as
the Beloved book and 1971 adaptation and
it starred Johnny Depp during the height
of his post-pirate star power this is a
prequel and stars Timothy chalamet who
may get fawning Praise on the award
circuit but isn't always a massive box
office draw more than one-third of his
all-time worldwide career earnings is
due to a small part in interstellar but
Warner Brothers got greedier than Veruca
Salt and gave this concept a green light
will it work out probably not expect to
see the Oompa Loompas showing up at
Warner Brothers HQ for Jonesy's song
about how making this movie was a huge
mistake Adam Driver in a jungle
surrounded by dinosaurs doesn't sound
too enticing which could be a bomb in
the making apparently 65 takes a route
similar to Planet of the Apes but with
Driver playing an astronaut who lands on
prehistoric Earth where dinosaurs reign
supreme 65 is co-written and co-directed
by Scott Beck and Brian Woods who
co-wrote quiet place with John Krasinski
the sci-fi horror Thriller also Stars
Adam Driver who despite starring in one
of the most commercially successful
trilogies of all time doesn't tend to be
much of a box office draw when he's not
playing people named kylo Ren perhaps 65
is one of the rare original sci-fi films
that can break out based on a modest
budget or maybe not the movie is
estimated to cost 90 million dollars
which might be somewhat modest by a
modern Hollywood standards but it's also
30 more than the 61 million dollar
budget for a quiet place part 2 and more
than five times the budget of a quiet
place the quiet play series was a
surprise success but those movies
relatively small budgets didn't exactly
hurt either making back this kind of
investment is a whole different ball
game however you'll no doubt c65's
marketing material making a big fuss
over the writer's connection to a quiet
place but the truth is that the
difference between those movies and this
one might as well be night and day
something that will likely be reflected
in its box office returns nobody would
blame you for doing a double take when
you saw that a Haunted Mansion movie is
being released in 2023 The Haunted
Mansion one of Disney's biggest
live-action failures of all time the
movie that pretty much killed Eddie
Murphy's career as an above the title
box office draw that Haunted Mansion Dad
yes I see dead people
yeah it's true given Disney's endless
parade of sequels prequels remakes and
reboots some might suspect the creative
well is running dry at the mouse house
but even this is a shock apparently
Disney is once again trying to make
movies based on theme park rides a thing
likely because it worked with the
Pirates of the Caribbean franchise for a
while at least according to Disney the
film is directed by Justin Simeon of
dear white people and stars Rosario
Dawson as a doctor and single mother to
a nine-year-old who moves to New Orleans
and finds herself in you guessed it a
haunted mansion she then turns to some
paranormal experts including a psychic
and a historian for Help vanquishing The
house's spooky specters unfortunately
there's a good chance that the only
thing Haunted Mansion will Vanquish is
Disney's money while it's slated for
theatrical release given the lackluster
reception to the first go-round the
chances are good that audiences won't be
happy to wait in line for this one in
2018 searching made 75 million dollars
worldwide on an 880 000 budget even
multi-million dollar blockbuster movies
would kill for that kind of
profitability let alone movies with
budgets smaller than the catering tab on
a Marvel movie however most people these
days have to go searching for searching
as the movie has pretty much vanished
from the public Consciousness undeterred
by this short shelf life five years
later Sony Pictures is giving the movie
a sequel according to vulture The Sweet
Spot for sequels is two to four years
unless it's a legacy sequel to A beloved
franchise missing misses that Mark by a
whole year will the audience show up for
the sequel It's hard to see it happen of
course Sony Pictures probably didn't
drop a ton of dough on this film so it
still may be profitable based on its low
budget alone but it's almost certainly
not going to come anywhere near its
predecessor's impressive box office
takings and whether it manages to make a
minor profit or not it's a safe bet that
missing will be conspicuously absent
from the year's top 50 worldwide
grossing films
[Music]